now if you do not have because it's been
a while for you the
tree expansion for this compound angle
in your head memorized
then that's part of what the reference
sheet is for so i'm going to show you
that result in a second where to find it
however i'm going to point out
you know especially in extension 2 level
this is really something that you want
to have committed to memory you want to
use it frequently enough that it's just
there ready to access you don't
experience that time penalty that you
always do
when you are going to the reference
sheet but that said let's make sure you
know where it is so you can find it in
case you can't quite remember what it is
this is page one of the reference sheet
and if you don't have it like in hard
copy you should just go and google nessa
reference sheet you'll find it
on page two you can see all of the
trigonometric functions and over here on
the left hand side
underneath compound angles there is the
one that we're interested in tan
and then you've got that compound angle
in there now the compound angle that
they give you is a plus b
so we need a minus b so one of the handy
things about this is that all of the
signs
just go backwards so instead of tan a
plus 10 b
on the numerator i'm going to have tan a
minus tan b on the numerator and then on
the denominator
instead of 1 minus tan a tan b i'm going
to have 1
plus 10 a 10 b
now if you're not sure why the signs
just reverse probably the easiest way to
have a think about it
is that because tan is an odd function
it has an
odd symmetry therefore tan of
negative b you know you can think of
this guy as
tan of a plus
negative b so i can fit this into the
formula that's handed to me on the
reference sheet
tan of negative b is just going to be
minus 10 b
that's part of the definition of an odd
function you get that on the top which
turns the plus sign into this minus that
we see
here and you get it again on the
denominator so this tan of negative b
i can simplify into negative 10
b that means that that minus and this
minus that was here they're going to
cancel out which gives me the plus that
you can see
all right so there's the result that i'm
after let's see what happens when i
actually start to
substitute that identity in here what
have i got
this is going to look a little bit messy
but i'm deliberately not going to skip
any steps because we do have the luxury
of time
here as i explain things so i'm just
going to show you what it looks like
as a big gobbled mess what is tan a well
it's going to be 10
of here here comes a right if you want
to think about it let's just highlight
it this way
this is the a there's the first angle
and this is the b it's the second angle
right
so therefore let's just use green since
i'm using it this is going to be my tan
of tan inverse five there's my tan a
i'm going to have minus tan of b on
the numerator as well so that's tan of
tan inverse
two-thirds
so that's my entire numerator tan a
minus tan b
and then on my denominator there we go
i'm going to have 1 plus 10 a
tan b so i'm going to be a little bit
cheeky and just grab this because i
pretty much wrote what i need up the top
here except i'm not subtracting them i
am multiplying them
there we go so i've got my tan a minus
10 b and then
on the denominator 1 plus 10 a 10 b
okay so as we anticipated before just
going to the next page
because of the um the niceness of tan
and tan inverse
tan tan inverse 5 is just 5. on
the numerator as well i've got 10 tan
inverse of 2 3 so i'm just going to get
minus 2 thirds there's the numerator
and then on the denominator it's 1 plus
i'm just going to multiply these
together
5 times two-thirds is ten-thirds
okay uh what's the best way to simplify
this well um i've got fractions on
fractions
i find fractions brain-hurting so i'm
going to get rid of as many fractions as
i can the easiest way to do that
is to multiply through by any
denominators in this case on the
numerator and the denominator it's going
to be 3.
so i'll multiply through by 3 on 3. that
gives me up on the top
15 minus 2 5 times 3
is 15 and then it cancels the uh the
two-thirds third part of that
and then on the denominator one times
three is three
plus ten thirds times three is just ten
right what am i getting uh this is
looking nice it's very promising on the
top you get
13 on the bottom you get 13 so you get
1.
alright so what have i done here well
i've actually done the first part of
what they asked me to do
in part b i have just found 10 of 10
inverse 5 minus 10 uh inverse two-thirds
so you could put this into your
calculator
and you could convince yourself you're
like wow all of that worked and the
answer that i got at the end was 1.
but what was the point of that well they
were saying do this
so that you can find r z well how do i
connect this result
one with arg z remember what i was doing
and
if i zoom out you'll see to evaluate one
this is the right hand side what's on
the left hand side well you can see what
i have here is tan of arg
z it's probably worth copying that down
to remind myself of what this line
actually means
tan of arg z equals 1. how do i use that
to find
arg z well i just take tan inverse of
both
sides and maybe because this is an exact
angle rather an exact value i should say
rather than five or two thirds
ten inverse of one is just going to be
pi on four
so this is part b i have found the
argument of z without finding where z
itself is it's pilot pion4 which is very
nice and neat
all right can we tie this all up in a
neat bow um i've got
the modulus of z i've got the argument
of z hence write z
in rectangular form where x and y are
real okay well i've got my modulus of z
we would
in in polar form we would usually call
that r
i've also got r z and we would normally
call that theta
so i'm going to say z this is part c
z by definition being in polar form r
times i might write that down r times
cos
theta plus i sine theta all i need to do
is substitute in
the r and the theta that i just found so
that's root two there's the first one
then i just got cos pi on four plus
i sine pi on four
all right time to evaluate these exact
angles
root two is out the front cos of pi on
four is one on root two
and then sine of pi and 4 is also
1 on root 2. so what's really nice here
is all of the colossal cancelling that
happens root 2
of course is just going to eliminate
everywhere and that just leaves me with
1
plus i and you can exhale
so there's a lot of work wasn't it but
the point of this was to illustrate how
do i use
um what i know from polar form about the
relationship between the modulus and the
argument
of the original complex numbers with the
quotient of those complex numbers
now i said right from the outset one of
the important things about being able to
use both rectangular and polar form
is knowing when to use rectangular or
polar form
in this case the whole point was to
nudge us toward what we understand from
polar form that's why we're talking
about
moduli and arguments in the first place
but
how we do this question if i just said
to you write z
in this form just just go ahead and do
the division
from the beginning this topic you would
have only known how to do this in
rectangular form so let's just do a
quick comparison and see
what it looks like and whether it's it's
better or worse
so i'll just do this different color
because it's not the actual question
i'm going to work out z by just doing
the division so it is let's just go back
and make sure i get the right numbers 1
plus 5
i 3 plus 2 i so 1 plus
5 i on 3 plus
2 i now in order to deal with this what
i would normally do is i would say oh
i need to realize this denominator so
i'm going to multiply by the conjugate
of the denominator
3 minus 2i on 3 minus 2i
in this case all right what am i getting
on the numerator let's start to
expand this out i'll distribute the 1 to
these first and then i'll distribute the
5i
so 1 times 3 minus 2y is just 3 minus
2i when i multiply through by 5i i'm
getting
15 i minus
10 i squared so there's the numerator
it's done
on the denominator i've got my
difference of squares happening so it's
3 squared minus
2i all squared all right let's start to
do some simplification here so you can
see you're going to get collecting like
terms
this real term and this real term this
minus 10 i squared is plus 10.
so 3 plus 10 is just going to give me
13.
that looks familiar minus 2i
plus 15i is going to give me minus sorry
it's plus 13i
that's great and then on the denominator
this should look familiar
because this 3 squared plus 2 squared
you can see that i squared is going to
come in there
that's something we had to evaluate
earlier when we were working out the
modulus of this second number right so
that's just from
from part a right so that's why it seems
familiar 3 squared plus 2 squared is of
course
9 plus 4 which is 13 so everything
cancels out
leave me with 1 plus i so i think
writing z there you can clearly see
compared to the way that the question
was posed to us in the first place this
was a simpler way
to go about it if what we wanted was x
plus iy
if what you want is an answer in
rectangular form
and the two complex numbers that go into
this were provided in rectangular form
there's not really a compelling reason
um to leave rectangular form
go out think about moduli and arguments
and then return to this okay
however if the question was just about
the modulus or is just about
the argument then it might be simpler to
actually instead of going
to work out the complex number itself
and then calculates modulus
or an argument you could go directly
there now we'll point out one of the
other things that makes this
this particular question harder to deal
with in polar form
work out those moduli and arguments is a
lot of the work that we did in this
question was in part b
which is sort of messing with the
arguments now messing with the arguments
in this case was hard
because the particular complex numbers
that we got given
they had messy arguments like 10 inverse
of 5 who knows what that is or 10
inverse of 2 3.
they're not nice and neat however you're
going to see several questions will have
exact values provided as arguments so
it'll be oh
the complex number will have an argument
of pi on 3 or pi on 2 or 5 pi on 6
all of these are going to be nice
numbers and so they lean you in the
direction of using polar form
rather than using the thirds that will
inevitably result when you have
rectangular form
so i guess what you're going to find is
questions will
tend to either give you nice numbers in
rectangular form you can see these are
all
nice neat integers they're even all
positive or they'll give you nice
numbers in
polar form which is to say everything
will be in terms of pies to give you
you know the exact values and the ratios
of the right angle triangles you're
familiar with
so those are the kinds of things that
give you clues about whether you should
use each
different form or again pay careful
attention to
what it is that they're asking of you
and
and
work out the most efficient path there